vanessa bryant says the nike shoes she
designed to honor her late husband and
daughter
kobe and gianna bryant have been leaked
and she's fuming over it insisting they
never should have been made
in the first place on thursday the 39
year old took to instagram posting
a lengthy message explaining that she
recently helped create a version of the
kobe 6 pro tro
that was intended to honor her late
husband and 13 year old daughter
who tragically died in a 2020 helicopter
crash
vanessa says the shoes she designed are
black and white
feature gianna's number two and have
other markings like a butterfly
wings and a halo the problem vanessa
parted ways with nike in the spring and
says she
never gave approval for the shoes to be
made and now
after seeing unverified images online
she claims they've been made
and leaked anyway posting this pic of
someone holding the shoe
in their hand in her statement posted to
instagram
vanessa explains quote nike has not sent
any of these pairs to me and my girls
i do not know how someone else has their
hands on shoes i designed in honor of my
daughter gigi
and we don't i hope these shoes did not
get sold
vanessa adds that she wanted the shoes
to be sold to honor her daughter with
all of the proceeds benefiting the mamba
and mambasita sports foundation
and an unverified instagram user who
originally posted photos of the
mambasita shoes nearly three weeks ago
claims nike is responsible for the shoe
leak
on thursday the unverified user posted a
statement to their insta story alleging
quote
i just want to make it clear that i
don't own a pair of those mambasita
kobes
the pictures i posted are official
product pictures from a nike authorized
retailer
the user continued writing unfortunately
for vanessa bryant
nike clearly sent pairs to this retailer
as well as others with the intent of
selling pairs
et has reached out to nike for comment
but it appears vanessa got more answers
she later responded to a fan's comment
claiming that nike told her the shoes
were in fact
made after she saw them posted online
but she says they were never supposed to
be sold adding quote
we were discussing releasing them after
all but the only way i will agree
is if hundred percent of all of the
proceeds
goes to mamba and mambasita sports so
that kobe and gianna's foundation is the
only entity that benefits from selling
gigi's mambasita shoes
you